The perfect form is no form.
Right?
Nobody wants to fill in forms.
And I mentioned before,
I wrote a book about web forms.
The first two words in
the book are forms suck.
Which is very true, right?
Nobody wants to go through that
process of filling in a form.
They want what's on the other side.
They want that ride from Uber.
They want the book from Amazon.
They don't want to sit there retyping
their name for the bizillonth time.
And ultimately it's almost
an insult to the person.
Technology is supposed
to change the world, but
the damn computer doesn't even
remember what my name is?
How many times must I type my name
into the same freaking computer
before it knows who I am?
Like I said, it's almost insulting
to people to treat them that way.
So my ultimate example of
the best form is no form.
And that's why I like these things
that get you down to a single tap or
something where you can
just instinctively say,
I want that and get what you want.
We are a long ways away from that,
in any case, but
there are a couple examples,
which was very promising.
And, usually, that's how things start.
Or you'll see one or two examples that
people say, oh, that's unachievable, but
gradually more and more people get to
that point and it becomes the new norm.